There is also the problem of jury selection.
Sitting on a jury is both a right and a duty.
Jurors are selected at random from people who are entitled to vote, who are under the age of 70.
The advantage of this is that, in theory, juries are composed of people...
...who come from a very wide spectrum of society.
Unfortunately, many people try to avoid their duty...
...because they claim they are too busy at work or will lose their salary.
As a result, juries, it is argued, have too many people with time,...
...such as unemployed and retired people, to provide a good balance.
Let us go back to the role of the jury.
In a trial, the jury's function is to decide on the facts of the case.
The jurors are there to determine the truth.
However, many cases have a highly emotive element...
...and this can, it is argued, sway the jury away from the facts.
Should emotion have a place in a court of law?
Can a group of twelve ordinary men and women provide a fair trial...
...and reach the correct verdict any better or worse than trained lawyers?
The government is keen to abolish trial by jury for some crimes...
...but surprisingly perhaps, the legal profession is not.
This, I think, is because we have an adversarial system...
...where lawyers need to argue the case against each other.